last night on the show we had this big
moment that i think
has resonated across the country that's
right we revealed the snack that joe
biden looks the most like
let me explain last week i asked my fans
to go to teamcocoa.com and vote on which
snack
joe biden looks the most like why did we
do this
well donald trump we know has been
compared to an orange cheeto
for four or five years now and we
thought okay that's done
but what snack item does joe biden the
new president resemble most
well guess what our fans overwhelmingly
chose
japanese shrimp chip i think that's a
good decision andy i
i i endorse it fully yeah this is
exciting wonders and now that we know
that according to america biden looks
like a
japanese shrimp chip we can now work
that comparison into our monologue jokes
and our monologue will be as edgy and
political as ever
let's get to it shall we check these out
today president-elect biden finally met
with president trump at the white house
the two men got along pretty well until
trump dunked biden in a ponzu sauce
[Laughter]
because of the shrimp chip yep
joe biden is polling surprisingly well
among libertarians
and even better among pescatarians
we're on fire you can't not like any of
these
i dare you internet these are perfect
yeah uh good god the biden people must
be just
[ __ ] themselves right now these are
so deadly
here we go joe biden is exactly like a
japanese
shrimp chip there were plenty of better
choices for your party
but if he's all you've got he'll do
wow ah man yeah that's a good one
here we go uh did you know both joe
biden
and shrimp chips have one thing in
common they both have a shelf life
of 120 years kazan
kazangaroo here we go
[Laughter]
biden is just like a shrimp chip in that
donald trump
will never have either one at the white
house for lunch
there's animosity between biden and
trump
and he wouldn't like a shrimp chip
anyway here we go
joe biden is just like a bag of shrimp
chips both recently spent four years on
the shelf
[Laughter]
yes yes
and that's it that's all we got oh
come on biden's lucky we didn't think of
this in june
yes yeah if we thought of japanese
shrimp chip in june he would not be our
president right now wow
we held off because this is devastating
yep what can you accomplish as a world
leader when everyone knows you look like
a japanese
shrimp chip yep this is going to
devastate him with world leaders
he's going to try and meet with
everybody to talk about the economy he's
gonna get together with other world
leaders they're gonna be like
here comes this shrimp chip
yeah anyway glad we held off
and uh congratulations america for
coming up with
the perfect snack food that
president-elect joe biden
looks just like